madame houda-pepin l'entrée en scène de
pierre karl péladeau à faire revenir la
souveraineté à l'avant plan
certains parlent encore de tamponnement
d'une élection référendaire
il ya des choses imprévues qui sont
arrivés ça vous quel effet savent ça en
brosse à ce que les fédéralistes risque
pop de revenir au parti libéral pour
s'assurer qu'ils répondent à notre
référence mais si les libéraux de la
pinière veulent voter libéral il
voterait pour une libérale
authentiquement fédéraliste et ça ne
s'appelle fatima houda pépin moi je suis
député je suis candidate indépendante
par la volonté de philippe briat je n'ai
jamais quitté le parti libéral du québec
gilles voiture et venir je n'ai jamais
on verra pour les choses les choix des
choses mais fondamentalement au moment
où je vous parle j'ai contribué pendant
20 ans au parti libéral du québec en
1995 pendant que gueye femme barrett
voté pour la séparation moi j'ai fait
deux sans trois cent trente rencontres
avec différents groupes au québec à
montréal a jusqu'à sherbrooke
pour défendre quoi pour défendre la
place du québec à l'intérieur de la
fédération alors votez fatima houda
pépin dans la pinière c'est voter
gagnant c'est voter authentiquement pour
une femme qui est qui soutient pour ses
convictions et être libéral et être
raide fédéraliste pour moi cela fait
partie de mes convictions une élection
où on parle beaucoup de références
je pensais pas que le parti québécois
allaient aller aussi allègrement vers ce
débat là c'est un choix qu'ils ont fait
ou presque de quoi décider de polariser
la société ça marche alors ça va être
nous contre eux parce qu est le seul
parti qui peut les arrêter c'est une
honte votre ancien parti fini impossible
ne peut pas le faire
écoutez gage d'un hip hop alpha et en
gt1 des voix à la santé etc crise
économique est venue à la santé il faut
les quais d'acadie
c'est fini pour moi personnellement mais
je dis si vous croyez que c'est terminé
il est clair il n'y a pas plu à vue pour
la partie et pour le québec il est clair
qu'elle la division du vote à la saveur
libéral parce que la caq c'est la saveur
libéral mais le pq au pouvoir je les
fais moi j'ai divisé le vote j'ai été
instrumental dans la mise en place d'un
gouvernement péquiste minoritaires j'ai
considéré pour moi que c'était une
erreur que j'ai décidé d'abord affaire
de voies